what up eli cliners
and welcome to another h3 podcast
today's episode is sponsored by me
undies naturebox
h3h3shop.com and twitch subscribers
like you thank you for supporting the
show everybody
another great little announcement i'm
very excited h3 podcast is now available
on spotify
[Music]
that's pretty awesome
you know we've been we've been really
waiting to get on spotify a lot of
people have been asking
so just search h3 podcast and it should
pop right up in there for you so you
know enjoy it anywhere yet be
yeah be everywhere anywhere you be we be
there right with you
now today's guest
is someone that i've known
very closely
for
over 10 years
she's a close personal friend
and some might even say my wife
technically that would be true some
would say
and spiritually also true
she's my best friend
she's my business partner and she's my
better half
bone
and she's bow in the house she's in the
house it sounded like that he's my best
friend it's my helper my son bo
um
we thought it'd be interesting look
we've we interview all these these uh
interesting prolific characters well
we've got one right here
that we all want to know more about gila
klein's one of the most interesting
people on the internet so we thought hey
i thought let's let's put her in the
seat
ela's not like hey let's interview me
that was my idea
well anyway she's really come out of her
shell lately
and what a big pimp
she's going back to the show she's back
in the show i've been nervous the whole
week about this
it's it it is stressful and i appreciate
you coming out because you are a
naturally very shy person
i don't know why it's nervous to think
of me as the guest like
because usually i'm like the second
you're chilling on the sideline i'm
chilling well you do you have
there was this one great moment and curb
your enthusiasm that i think you really
identified what was it larry said i
identify with everything on curb
but
um he was talking about how when he has
something during the week like a meeting
or a doctor or whatever it ruins the
whole week for him because he knows that
he has to think about that one thing
that he has to do right
like that yeah i relate to that but i
think you relate more
that's why i love it you're the best
well let's start from the top here i
want to talk about some current events
with you all right
now everybody's probably aware of all
this business happening first harvey
weinstein
this guy he looks like shrek if i'm
being honest like like a real version of
shrek he looks pretty scary yeah he's a
and now like nobody cared about harvey
weinstein because he's just some
soulless movie executive and they're
like oh he raped a bunch of people no
surprise but now it came out that louis
ck
was someone that i know you cared deeply
about
has been jerking off
this is this thing he's been jerking off
in front of of uh girls
it's so weird so how do you feel about
all that
i i felt really sad
like yesterday especially when the whole
story like officially came out
i don't know it's just sad
uh
for some reason with someone like harvey
weinstein i don't care as much yeah
it's it's sad in a different way just
said that it happens yeah
but with louie i kind of feel like he
died yesterday kind of feel like
i'm not going to see him anymore like
damn that's true in a way i'm sure
it's just weird what's he going to write
up she's going to write a shtick about
how oh should girls might be my dick huh
he can't do that and his jokes are
always kind of like that like
everyone was talking about how he has a
lot of jokes so like
men are so gross how
women
how do women even get close to men
because they're like the number one
threat but obviously when he says it's
funny right
but now it's gonna be weird
does it surprise you the these things
coming out because it's like a land it's
like a waterfall a landfall
i wasn't surprised at first
i feel like every woman
in a way goes through something of that
sort which is crazy but i think almost
all women that i met
and we talk about it are like not
surprised
but it's it's been so many stories all
of a sudden at once that i am becoming
surprised and then with louie i was
surprised i didn't see that oh louie it
was like not louie like anyone but louie
but he
he did he did write like his statement
about it right which was pretty good i
thought and i just feel bad for him now
do you want to read it i have it
available i mean it's kind of long but
essentially he was like
it's kind of long people can read it but
is you can tell he's really
hurting now from
understanding maybe what he's done maybe
before he didn't understand
he said in his apology he justified it
by saying well i asked girls first if i
could show them my dick yeah but he
acknowledges like the situation is much
more complicated than that so even if
you say yes at the moment
as the lady even if she said yes at the
moment i think the situation is so
surreal you're like with one of your
idols right and you're thinking at the
moment this is weird but i don't know
what to do so you say yes
but later not even expecting him to
necessarily even you think he's kidding
or something yeah but later you can
think about it and be like that was
really [ __ ] up so right
i think the way he did it specifically
because
it's it's one thing to go on a date and
be like hey i've got a weird thing can i
i want to jerk off in front of you but
this was like
he just got off stage
and they were coming about to do a set
or something like in a professional
environment it's when
weird is
do you think that he was going to get
away with it after doing this for so
long and it's so weird and brazen like
how do you think he could but uh harvey
weinstein this is a weird timing right
now
and like kevin spacey is now that one
shocked me too
i the way i see it is like these guys
like
that's it they're done you're not gonna
see anything with these guys anymore
maybe for like 20 years maybe in 20
years you can come back and be like
remember when i was a gross
guy who
jerked in front of people right big
laughter lots of applause he's so brave
it's crazy man yeah
well
rest in peace louie
it was fun while it lasted
i i just it's it's just a shitty
situation i feel bad for both sides
obviously it did something disgusting
that he shouldn't have done
but
you know like
the fact that he put out a good
statement i'm not saying that
that's it we can forgive him sure but it
made me feel bad for him too you know i
feel bad for everyone
it's important because when you look at
how kevin spacey for example responded
that was that was lame he's like sorry i
was drunk and anyway i'm gay
are you like okay yeah gays do that yeah
yeah that totally explains that we all
we all play around with 14 year olds
when we're drunk don't we yeah but it's
isn't it kind of
that was one of the weirdest apologies
ever yeah my god dude
um but louis he really seems to be
grappling with
this new image of himself because he's
not he's different now
his life his image his career it's all
undergone an immediate paradigm shift
yeah
and he's grappling with that and he had
so many things coming out and it's all
cancelled now yeah a movie
that this company put in five million in
that movie for him and they're like
they're apparently not a big company so
it was a big
investment for them that's awful and you
had a netflix special planned that's
going to be cancelled
a bunch of stuff i saw this meme on
reddit that was written as like a
perfect louis ck joke that he would say
if it was about someone else
he was like um
it's a shame that the greatest
comedian of our generation is going down
in his prime but maybe
maybe you should have shown your penis
to a bunch of uh girls backstage without
their consent
yeah
obviously his delivery is much better
yeah but i feel like he could deliver
that joke very well mm-hmm anyway let's
get off this [ __ ]
yikes
what okay let's start from the top here
in terms of of uh
who you are you're israeli i think most
people know that by now what's it like
growing up in israel like i mean us
americans do we take [ __ ] for granted
um
it's a it's like a very general question
uh
yes
a little bit
about what you said about americans i
feel like since i moved here especially
in california
it's kind of like utopian
society
and um so i can kind of see why there's
like this whole arguments between white
privilege and
people feeling guilty and so they're
trying to like correct things way too
much you know
um
yeah growing up in israel is very
different than here
but it's also kind of the same also kind
of the same yeah
well
is it is it awful in israel i feel like
a lot of people think it's awful there i
think people just riding around in
camels and [ __ ] yeah that's not a thing
right
um
it's kind of like here like you just
watch the same shows on tv the same
movies you go to theaters you have a job
you go to school you drive your car not
not camels
you don't
uh when you finish high school you go to
the army that's different than here
that's a huge difference and then when
you're done with the army then you go to
college so it you kind of like
everything takes a little longer than it
does here interesting
um what are the big differences beyond
that
between israel and the united states
um
i think the mentality of people is very
different
here and there um
and obviously the security situation not
not being under threat here
is
it just causes so much like you know in
uh
as a result of it that it's just so
different like
in israel there's always that threat
over your head
but you you just grow up like that so
you're not thinking about it's just what
it is
so when i'm here i can see
i can see how different it is like what
what threats specifically is it that
your
israelis
think about um
for example growing up like if i wanted
to go out or to go to a mall my dad
would be like don't go there's a lot of
people there
like if you go to a crowded place it's a
it's a
it's a threat it's a dangerous spot
because there could be a suicide bomb
there or
it's like a
what do you call it's an attraction for
a terror attack right
it's when you're in a crowd in israel
you actually think like yeah this is
this could be a little bit risky yeah
for me personally
that's interesting because a lot of
people in the usa
sometimes tend to think like shit's not
safe here because they're afraid of
immigrants or yeah that's pretty well
people with guns or
you know
it's pretty strange although lately the
the all the gun
stuff
is kind of
kind of going in that direction it's
still very far like the usa is huge
israel is tiny yeah
um
so
but in israel yeah there's always like
some kind of
there's always a new type of attack
that's happening
and then that that happens for a while
until israel figures a way to like
prevent it right so when i was growing
up there was a lot of uh suicide bombs
like in cafes and buses and stuff like
that and then
like recently it was a stabbing like
you could just be waiting for a bus and
then someone would just come and stab
you
on the street
and so that's
it's but israel is really crazy they
figure out ways to prevent this stuff
like the stabbing was happening for a
few months
and now it doesn't really happen so much
and i don't even know how they have like
their secret ways
say what you will about the israelis man
but those guys are [ __ ] innovative
yeah
they they're figure [ __ ] out there man
but
people who would like to criticize the
army and israel need to understand that
it's a daily threat that needs something
needs to happen about it's not like we
have a choice
do you do you find it ironic when that
like there's these
when you talk about privilege let's talk
about someone who's going to uc berkeley
paid by their parents 200 000 tuition on
campus protesting israel do you find
that ironic
i do when i lived in israel i used to
criticize israel a lot yeah as an
israeli yeah and the army and a lot of
stuff
but when i kind of when i when we moved
here and i started to go on reddit and
stuff like that and just being more
aware of like the online
criticism that and there's not just
online but it's not just yeah i just
became more aware of like the criticism
here of israel
and in general around the world
and it's really
i i personally think it's so ironic like
it's just like i don't know it's kids
sitting here in like beautiful
california criticizing it like you don't
even know what you're talking about
right
yeah it totally i mean it's it's easy
to reduce it's funny because like you
said when you're in israel you're super
critical yeah of the government you're
like dude you're expanding in the west
bank that's [ __ ] you know the
government is turning off water and gaza
doing weird [ __ ] to control uh and make
land grabs and stuff and that kind of
stuff is like yo what are you guys doing
but when you come to israel and then you
what you hear is people criticizing
national security and saying calling
israel like apartheid that they
shouldn't have fences or that israel
should be
you mean when you come here and you're
here right exactly like less let's say
less specific criticism or more general
like
they build a wall and they and israel
should be a one state with palestinians
and israel all living together they
should reduce the borders and remove the
gate that that to me seems like
super ignorant it is because when i grew
up i couldn't really take a bus i was
afraid of blowing up right and now it
doesn't really happen so the wall did
help
so should we not have a wall can you
explain about the wall for people who
don't know about it
i don't know
how to explain well i guess simply it's
like it was built to prevent this
attacks and
there's still a lot of other ways
there's tunnels and you know yeah
rockets yeah
but when we when elo was a kid
there was no wall around greater israel
that blocked out the west bank and gaza
and it was like for i remember in the
newspaper when you were growing up
there was
almost daily right
not daily but it was happening a lot and
it was terrifying yeah on in cafes
and
um shopping malls and buses
and it was just like a slaughter it was
just a slaughter
and so they're like oh let's build a
[ __ ] wall then and and lo and behold
no more suicide bombs my whole time
there
my whole five years living there there
was like one failed shitty attempt
actually it wasn't even a suicide bomb
someone threw a bomb at a bus from the
outside and it didn't kill anyone
so
i don't know it's like at a certain
point you do you know you ha does it
justify like how do you
how do you think about the gazans who
are on the other side of the wall now
who are like
cut off from family members who have to
go through checkpoints and come to
israel you know it's like
the whole thing is shitty
the whole situation there is shitty
no matter how you look at it
so i don't know
i
it's like you just i don't know i was
just born there so
there's a lot of people who are just
born there and
they need to be able to live their life
right sure and israel was made
for that purpose because they were being
chased in all the other countries where
they came from
so
i don't know
it's obviously super complicated i'm not
i don't think i'm
qualified to like talk about this stuff
in
actual detail and what what is the
solution i have no idea yeah
i think that's honestly one of the best
answers though because everybody likes
to act like
in [ __ ] 1957
some air some jew threw a stick out of
here or i don't know
but it's like it's way too complicated
for one person to actually have
a really good
opinion about it yeah and it's so
confusing too that even if you do it's
like how do you even
how do you even break that down but i
but i will say
it's more
it's more complicated than like the
people who just hate israel for
everything they stand for
that's my main point
i i would criticize israel for a lot of
stuff but
just to
the way people like to criticize it is
as if it was just black or white like
it's just not
do you you served in the military
and your whole family served in the
military right
what did uh how was your experience in
the military
um
it was okay
i i didn't do anything like i wasn't
like a combative
role yeah you weren't a fighter i wasn't
a fighter
so
i didn't have anything like crazy to
tell but
um
i don't know it's kind of like a
it's kind of like a mandatory job that
you have to go to
and you don't get paid for yeah
someone said is it like a forced
vacation
no
no it's more like a fourth job forced up
because you what did you do what was
your role in the military
um at first i was given a role that was
like in an office
somewhere close to my house in tel aviv
and
it was kind of like going to a day job
in an office
um
it happened right after there was some
kind of a
second war in
where was it
yeah there was some sort of a
small
war yeah
when i was there and um
so my job was to like when they sent
officers or like people
to go serve
i had to like
logistically
help with like their hotel or a room
okay things like that but it was all on
the computer it just felt like
some computer thing right okay so
secretary yeah interesting and it was
super boring and i really hated it
because it was just like
i had to take in a bus super early
go there spend the whole day go back
home
i hated it
so i tried to change my
role
and um it was something like you can
apply for it and it's a form that you
fill out and then they're gonna give you
something else completely random
different post yeah different location
so i decided to do that and if i don't
like the second one then i'll just find
a way to get out of the army because
that bad
yeah i just didn't i hated everything
about it didn't want to do it
um
you just because if you're doing
something that it felt like i wasn't
doing anything i was just wasting my
life yeah
it could get really frustrating i don't
know right
and you gotta do it for two years right
so i tried i filled out that form and i
tried it and then
i somehow ended up in a better place
that i liked a lot more
um
before it was a daily thing where you go
back home every day
and the new one was in a way that was a
base that was far from my house so you
go there for the whole week and then you
come back for the weekend so you
preferred that were you gone for all
week i did
interesting why
it was kind of like just more of an
adventure more of it
different experience
that i preferred than to just go to a
boring job
sit on the computer and go back home at
the end of every day i don't know were
you doing secretary work there
so yeah i was the secretary of the head
of the
um
there's like a i don't know the terms in
english from the army right here's a
translator
so there was a i was in
which is like a
like a brigade i guess
that's in charge of the
area of ramallah
and that brigade has like a main officer
so i was his secretary okay so you were
right below the big boy
cool so it was nice it was interesting
um
it was more demanding in a way
but also
kind of more rewarding because you're
put in this weird situation where you're
like you don't you're away from your
house
you have this new group of people that
you have to get along with
and
i it's hard to explain but for some
reason it was more interesting i enjoyed
it more
you told me once you went on like a
mission with them mm-hmm to like a
terrorist city
yeah that was kind of a crazy story yeah
the
so my officers and like the
the soldiers in that brigade
um they would go every night on
a raid right in armada to to arrest
terrorists
and um
so i always saw them preparing for it
and leaving and then i would stay in the
basement so one time i wanted to go with
them just to experience it why you just
were all of a sudden
had an urge to go with them
i just wanted to see what it's like
right i wanted to see it okay
so um
yeah they took him they took me with
them one night even though they weren't
supposed to
did they armor your ass up
um
you're driving in this like jeep that's
uh bulletproof right so i was in the [ __ ]
and then um
as soon as we entered ramallah
the
people in the city started shooting us
wow and i heard like a bullet here the
egypt like right next to my head did you
did it like dent or just hear it it's a
gnarly armored jeep mm-hmm okay
and
i mean it was just interesting
they were shoot so someone actually was
shooting the car when you went in there
right away yeah huh did you have a gun
on you
i didn't you're not supposed to leave
no yeah not really but even if i
i mean i i walked with them to one house
okay i did get out of the car once
but but surrounded with them okay
did they arrest anyone that night they
did did they bring it in the same car
with you no oh
there's a few
cars are going damn that's crazy
was it like how did you feel was it
horrifying
it was strange
very
very weird how should like how so
um
i don't know just
you see people in the house and then
it's like
the soldiers go just walk into the house
and
look through their [ __ ] and find guns
and
the whole thing is really surreal
they just
do they knock or they just like kick
down a door and charge in
i didn't really see that home
i don't know exactly how that was does
it feel like a normal neighborhood
or does it feel like oh this is scary no
it actually looked like a nice city
that's straight yeah that's i mean from
their perspective well
it's so complicated yeah
from their perspective it's like
[ __ ] these guys but they go specifically
to people who they know are terrorists
and they have history of
that stuff and they know they have guns
right
even if that's true it's hard if you're
that guy's neighbor not to be like i
hate yeah these [ __ ]
and i'm scared of them coming to my
house someday even though i'm not a
terrorist
yeah it's a lot of responsibility
oh that shit's heavy did any of your
family member i mean all your family
members served in the military do any of
them have crazy stories or crazy [ __ ]
that happened to them
yeah they had crazier stuff than me what
what does anything come to your mind i i
wouldn't know but i mean both my
brothers were
did pretty serious stuff
uh moses was
he was um
learning to become a pilot
so the training for that alone is like
the most insane training
that there is
right
and my other brother
um he was in tanks
so
they also had i'm sure he had a lot of
stories i don't know them though that
shit's great yeah they probably have
insane stories every israeli i've spoken
to served has like really disturbing
crazy [ __ ]
i know that one story about your brother
he was a security guard at the embassy
and at the same time there was a suicide
bomb
right next to it there's this american
diner what do you call it
oh the
bar yeah bar it's like a restaurant bar
and it's right next to the us embassy in
this really touristy place and hila's
brother
am i saying right he was on post at the
embassy
yeah
i don't remember if it was at my mike's
place though i know that mike's place
was bombed yeah but i think that was a
separate time oh okay everybody gets it
back in that
anyway there was like this awful suicide
bomb
and some place right next door to the
embassy and he was standing right
[ __ ] like 10 feet away
and he's not allowed to leave his post
and it's probably especially at a time
like that
you gotta stand guard
so he was stuck standing there right i
don't remember exactly the story
okay
but
anyway everybody's got stories from that
from that era yeah it's all twisted up
dude
um
are there lessons disciplines
is things that you learned you know that
you retained from that period in your
life how did it change you going through
that
i'm not sure that it changed me
um
i think the biggest thing is just like
being put in a place
with a group of people that maybe
in
normal life you wouldn't necessarily
become friends with
but in this situation you just become
friends with them and they become your
family
so
that aspect of it was interesting
but i mean i don't know
it was just some [ __ ] job for you
for two years
anyway okay
all right well
we got that uh we got the military [ __ ]
some pretty heavy duty stuff
uh we'll take a quick thank you to our
sponsors up next we've got so much great
stuff to talk about
guys don't go away
stay tuned
and thank you to our sponsor me undies
me undies makes undies your butt will be
proud to wear
well
and check this out we're not the only
ones that love meundies listen to what
our longtime listener mandy's enthusiast
christian had to say
uh this is a note from a good fan of
ours ryan childler that that wrote a
very fine comment about this mendes he
said when i first heard ethan read in
meundie's ad i thought he was an irish
person trying to say me undies
they sound irish there beyond is
maybe there myandis
however after reading many online
reviews about how soft and comfortable
they were i decided to finally pull the
trigger because i wanted to pair those
life-changing undies
when i slipped on my first glorious pair
of me undies i felt like the clouds
parted in the sky and a beam of light
was illuminated right up my
ass again he says he said rear end but i
think that
let's let's not mince words there was a
beam of light shining in and out of his
ass it was glorious they were so
comfortable that i knew that the world
was never going to be the same because
of me undies my ass is a whole lot
happier to ethan and neela thank you for
doing such a great job for always
sharing your sick memes with listeners
like myself well thank you so much ryan
appreciate you and thanks for supporting
the show and putting on those life light
beaming life-changing undies
listen my friends your ass
your quality of life going on and your
ass can change now forever like it did
to young ryan
get 20 off the best and softest
underwear and socks you will ever own
free shipping and a 100
ass
satisfaction guaranteed go to
meundies.com
h3 that is meundies.com
h3 ela what are we working with here
ela's falling off
me undies has got her falling all over
the place
here i wanted to show this one yeah this
one of their new designs i guess what is
it froot loops it's like milk and cereal
oh my god my my my crotch area already
feels like a swamp and now i can get a
visual representation of it too
but with these let me tell you
less swampy
thanks miandi appreciate you up next
thank you to a nature box
listen
we all want to eat better but when it
comes to snacks sometimes it feels like
it's all delicious and a billion
calories versus boring and tasteless
there's got to be something in between
and guess what there's something
way beyond the middle into the i can't
believe it's
not true because it's so good
talking about nature box okay because
these guys make delicious snacks that
are also healthy
nature box has over 100 snacks that
taste good and are actually better for
you
they're all made from high quality
simple ingredients which means no
artificial colors favors or sweeteners i
get out of breath
easily should i be concerned about that
well maybe we'll talk about that later
but
i'll tell you what does help nature box
snacks
so you can feel good about what you're
eating
my favorite
cashew coconut i'm a cashew boy my
favorites are the cashew coconuts
the shirachi cashews i actually i have a
lot of favorites the the chedda lentil
loops and let me tell you what else the
medley
sweet uh sweet and salty nuts a medley
it's like when you have um
you know like these old-timey they stand
on the street corner and they sing words
they they sing it's like a whole thing
it's like that but with snacks i have no
idea what you're talking about you know
like
beautiful voices symphonies that's
what's happening with the nuts
okay it's a medallion i've never seen
that on the street though
really
we got to get out more
it's a whole medley of nuts sweet and
sour my god listen you're sure to find
your new snack obsession at naturebox
they add new snacks every month inspired
by real customer feedback the latest
view trends and professional chefs
it's so simple just go to naturebox.com
choose the snacks you want and nature
box will deliver them right to your door
ladies and gentlemen and there's no risk
have you ever tried a snack you don't
like guess what don't eat it
they'll replace it
for free
my god that's that's genuine right there
and there's you know listen right now
nature box is offering h3 fans 50 off
their first order
go to naturebox.com
h3 that's
naturebox.com slash h3 to get 50 off
very cool your first order of some of
the bombest snacks in the world you can
eat them and you don't have to feel bad
because it's a joy and it's a privilege
to get mentally nuts like they make
right
nuts like this they don't come around
often
so go to naturebox.com h3 thank you so
much and finally
we are sponsored by oh my god who is
this h3h3shop.com
that's us
halo you want to show
yes we've got this vintage limited
edition
vape
always rep your niche
ladies and gentlemen always
and for our podcast listeners we are
doing a little bit of a black friday
special
rep your niche with the spec
damn boy that is
hardcore code h3 for 30
off go to
h3h3shop.com and use code h3 at checkout
for 30 off anything in the store
appreciate you guys so much if you are
in the market for some snacks
or some bingo underwear or socks or all
the great stuff they make please by all
means support our sponsors because they
support us they make this possible thank
you so much and now we will get back
with uh
she's right here
ela kleiner for life welcome back to the
h3 podcast live
eli kleiner's mount the [ __ ] up
what up what up
so um
we figured out the whole israel thing
we figured it out it's all settled now
how
people were wondering this on the
subreddit they were putting down down
questions for you
um how what could a guy like me
convince a girl like you to move to
america
okay
um
in israel hold on one sec dan you're
coming through the speaker
sorry god
in israel when people finish the army
usually
a lot of people would want to go
somewhere to do like a big trip
for like
a few months
to like
clear your head before you're gonna go
into
whatever is next in your life right
so i kind of
i finished my army and
it was kind of like a good timing to do
that it was convenient timing for me
yeah i got you at the perfect time
otherwise no chance well we
whatever
no but
um
it was just it kind of made sense i
wanted to do a trip anyway right um i
don't know if i would have done it to
the states necessarily but
that kind of like just
well worked out wasn't there somewhere
else you were thinking of traveling
um
a lot of people will go to india or
south america for some reason it's just
cheaper it's closer
yeah
it's weird there's like this whole
pilgrimage of israelis when they finish
the army when you go to places like
thailand and india
it's just like it's like the natives
there speak hebrew
there's so many
hello sweetie
that's all i know
hello sweetie do you want to watch me
masturbate mock away sweetie
maybe not there let's not go there
well um
how did you hand well okay so
the story is
i mean everyone knows the story right
now but you moved to to america
in essence to live with me
how did your i'm curious how did your
family handle
that did they think you were in totally
insane to be like i'm moving in with
this american guy yeah they weren't
happy
um my dad didn't want me to go
and
yeah they're they
they disapproved
of that
yeah
i remember you having some pretty gnarly
yeah
but
i just it felt like the right thing for
me to do and i just knew
i wasn't gonna be happy
not doing it right
so i just
did it
i've always said about you you don't you
don't have like an israeli soul
you have like an american soul
does that make sense i do
i do like it here because i think what
you mean by that is the the mentality
difference
i think you're just
more in israel people are like
kind of intense they're like in your
face all the time
whenever we work with israelis here in
the states like i get a little
flashback to what it's like there
because they're so like
well immediately they ask you super
personal questions and they're like
as if it's like i'm talking to my uncle
or something like a guy i never met yeah
um
so i feel like i like hear how
people kind of give each other their
space
that's very true you can live in your
bubble
no one's going to question anything
you can be like you can shake your dick
here yeah and sure
um but i feel like
you're always very uh motivated you're
always inspired for something bigger a
bigger life than what a lot a lot of
israelis are just like i'm gonna have a
kid
i'm gonna work at uh supercell
whatever
and that's it that's it and it's uh
that's fine if that's you're satisfied
living like that but i don't feel like
that was ever
in the cards for you
it is kind of like the ideal there
all
the parents you know they want you to
get married have kids right that's you
made it buy a house
yeah
a house in a family yeah that's like
that's all anyone could dream for mm-hmm
i mean in a way that's true to an intent
here but there's more here yeah there's
more people want more i want that but i
want to do more before i get into that
right you know
it's the american dream
here yeah
you had the american dream in israel
i guess it's weird i never like thought
about it but i guess i had that inside
of me but i never
thought like oh the american dream i
want to pull and
that's not the america the american
dream is like i guess making more of
yourself becoming bigger and better
version of yeah dreaming to
you know
transform into something better
and bigger
i think it was somewhere inside of me
but not something i was constantly
thinking about
here's a question from dino i
some of these questions i'm just going
to completely paraphrase because i feel
like it's weird for me to ask it so this
one is dino
zahiro from the subreddit he says how
did it feel how did it feel meeting
ethan for the first time we always hear
ethan's side of the story but i want to
know what your initial reaction to
meeting him was because i'm because you
know i've told the story a thousand
times so from your perspective
how does it line up what do you remember
um
i remembered that ethan was very nice
wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't know we just for some reason
we're like in the same
like we just connected on like
at
some kind of basic level we were just
like on the same page it felt like
and
ethan was very sweet
got him
i don't know it was just nice and we
didn't show you my dick
no
got him twice
but it was just weird we just like we
had this week together in the in
birthright the trip yeah and we just
enjoyed spending that time together
on like a friendship
level it's just fun
got drunk
that's true we did drink a lot but like
and how did that how did you perceive
the language barrier because i know
it was pretty difficult for us to
communicate back then
so weird think about yeah
but i i guess it felt like we were still
able to communicate somehow yeah we
found a way
i found it
okay it lines up you see
it's none of this like oh this so this
fat [ __ ]
american showed me his dick
he locked me in a room and he said
follow me on facebook
that's actually a interesting detail
yeah i never i didn't even know what
facebook was this is a long time ago
birth right and
when it when it ended everyone wanted to
stay in touch
so all these americans were like get
facebook let's stay in touch on facebook
and you guys were all like what is
facebook how weird is that huh
and now every uh
now every israeli every orphan
every like
man woman and child on this planet
crazy
um
do your friends and family back in
israel understand the level of of
success that you've achieved with
or do they or is it just a complete
different language to them
yeah
it's mostly
like i have this three
um childhood friends
that every time i go to israel we meet
yeah
and it's really funny they have no idea
what we're doing or
one of them mayan
she kind of follows she kind of knows
and
she
she like she knew that we passed five
million subscribers oh okay so she told
me congrats that's cool for example
right but the other two like have no
idea what we do
and every time we meet it's like the
same things they're like so how what are
you doing how are you doing okay and are
you working are you guys struggling yeah
and
i'm trying to like no we're doing like
very good
and they're doing very well it's worth
to try to explain it i don't know
yeah we
i i try sometimes i've showed them a few
videos
yeah and move on yeah i hate i hate
showing my videos to people
especially when they really don't get it
or care
like what do you do here here's my
husband in underwear yelling
at a monitor they're like oh good
yeah
you guys are doing really well you're
right so you're looking for a real job
yeah and it's always like
yeah so
do you have any do you have a second job
or
um my parents started following though
that was a crazy development yeah
like my dad apparently shares everything
you post on facebook like i didn't even
know incredible
for a while i didn't even know my friend
told me and about it you unfollowed your
dad on facebook right yeah you committed
the cardinal sin
there was a long time ago we made one of
our first videos and i posted on
facebook and my dad saw it and got super
mad
what was it
the shake your dick
of all the [ __ ] videos we've ever
made
back in the day we made this parody of
uh shake what was it shake that ass
shake that thing yeah by sean paul shake
that thing
come on come on so we made this parody
called shake that dick
and there shows a lot of close-ups of my
dick shaking like you know under the
paper i know their pants yeah yeah
i mean i wouldn't i would never in my
wildest dreams this is a pretty
embarrassing video and yeah it's awful
i've removed it
but my dad got super mad like
way too much so
well you didn't know what he said he
said
if if you guys keep making videos i'm
gonna denounce ethan
and they can't walk into our house
i was like look dude
[Laughter]
so
that's fine
i unfriended my dad and i was like okay
so we don't need to be friends on
facebook
and that was a few years ago and then we
became pretty successful and our videos
got kind of better yeah i'm sure they
got better
but i had no idea that he was sharing
all of our stuff
now he's the biggest fan yeah i gotta
make a shake that dick part two just to
see how reacts now
but
yeah i mean i could yeah your dad has
been
he's been great he um
what what happened with the sandals i
remember that i don't remember what
happened with that
um
[Music]
you decided that you only wear socks and
sandals one day as i'm all responsible
adults hard-working mature adults not
the regular sandals the flip-flops like
the one that goes into your toe
i don't see their that distinction is
important there's a difference okay all
right apparently your dad agreed
so
we used to go to my parents every friday
because in israel it's like a friday
meal it's like a big family yeah it's a
family event
and nathan would come like that and my
dad got upset like took me aside and
asked me can you tell him to stop
dressing like that
that was it was that it i for some
reason i remember it was like uh
powerful it was like
if you ever wear socks and sandals to to
our house again on shabbat my dad will
disown you that's possibly he did
possibly he probably said that yeah he
doesn't speak your dad's not the kind of
guy but can you please ask anything to
put on
to put on shoes and here's the thing
that i didn't really get about that
everyone takes their shoes off when they
get to the house so how does he know
if i wore it if i wore a thousand dollar
gucci dress shoes
after that first second of stepping foot
in the house there would be literally no
difference it's the five minutes of you
walking out of the house into the street
and the neighbor seeing you
that would be embarrassing that's what
it is isn't it
that is what it is
well now he's our biggest fan so
shout out
and we actually saw him one day wearing
socks and sandals remember recently that
was like just that was like as good as
when joey salads was caught faking that
that uh prank in the hood
when i heard your dad was walking around
in socks and sandals i was just like
oh yes dude full vindication and your
family gave him [ __ ] too right yeah and
my mom was like what the [ __ ]
you told ethan not to do it
what do you say
he laughed
oh oh that was funny huh
i disown you son-in-law
oh i guess i'll do it yeah he's a great
guy
shout out to yokon
keep wearing those socks in santa man
even against your own will put those on
he doesn't really he only did it once
someday we're gonna have to put on socks
and sandals and just take a stroll
together it's like a peace offering
that would be great eli doesn't want to
see that it's too embarrassing
all right
what's it like being a female youtuber
for you
because it's interesting we sit next to
each other we make videos together i'm a
man you're a female
people do react to us differently
for example you're always getting for
example the first question on the
subreddit was are you pregnant yeah you
know
um
we already have both of our parents
pestering us about your
pregnancy statement so you need a
million additional people asking funny
my mom
she followed me on instagram right and
she saw i posted a picture of me with my
nephew and all the comments were like
you look so good with a name you guys
should have a baby what are you pregnant
like when is it blah blah a million
comments about that right and my mom saw
that and she was like
now i understand that i don't even need
to ask you like you have a million
people asking you because because my mom
always wants to know yeah when is it
happening
so it was funny so she had a little bit
of moment of she's like okay i'm gonna
stop because that's pretty considerate
yeah
but being a like and then another one
like
i know when we did the episode with the
doc the doctor disrespect everyone was
posting clips
of ela smiling staring at documentary
like get cooked ethan
does that [ __ ]
that one did
i was triggered
because it's so dumb
and like
i do that with every guest i always
smile and i i play with my hair
nervously even when i'm upset like it's
completely unrelated to
i don't know finding him i don't even
know how is that related
that's like something from a cartoon
that's not real life
[Music]
the whole podcast on the twitch chat
that was the only thing i saw like
everyone
was talking about how i'm like into him
whatever
that's that's something that annoys me
that i don't
i just don't get it
my thing with that is like i've never
seen that response people were so
neurotic about it they were going to our
subreddit and posting like
keep posting it
and i've never seen people respond to a
guest like that and my thing was like
these guys want to [ __ ] him
right these are the guys who are
insecure they think because i that i was
very normal if that's what you see in me
it's like then maybe you're reflecting
something yeah of your own i think they
all want to [ __ ]
they all want doc balls deep on them
which is fine
yeah god bless them
but there's definitely something like
deep there about their insecurities it's
kind of annoying and it's kind of
chauvinistic i guess because it's like
if a girl smiles to a guy it's like oh
yeah are you into you want a date it's
like no i'm just being nice too
you have that a lot with the
yeah guys yeah giving your [ __ ] smile
more do you get that yes unless there's
and and it's like it's i would i don't
want to smile because i don't want you
to think that i'm start hitting on you
right and then it's like hey why are you
not smiling it's
on both ways you're going to get
criticized
interesting
it used to happen to me a lot
and like nowadays we don't go out so
much we're always we stay in the house
at the house and in la there's not much
walking to do you're always driving yeah
but in other places where we've lived
it would happen to me a lot
i see an elo get she gets attitude boy
and i love it or someone i'll walk and
someone would be like
nice eyes oh yeah
and it's gonna hurt so if you're like if
you're gonna be nice in response they
think
the the next sentence is gonna be like
can i have your number right
if you're not nice like
what's wrong with you except the
compliment [ __ ]
yeah yeah
huh
i've seen i've seen that happen to you
firsthand
and there's nothing wrong with like
trying to hit on a girl but sometimes
it's just uncomfortable and you don't
want it at every turn
if you're just walking down the street
doing errands you don't want or if
you're in a taxi with a driver it's
pretty inappropriate that's bad so it
happens in pretty inappropriate
situations a lot interesting
um
more generally do comments on the
internet get to you
does that [ __ ] bother you sometimes
it does
i always try to um
i've been through different phases i
feel like lately i'm not so much
but there was a time when it did i think
i've learned kind of to distance myself
from the comments
i don't know because two phases i agree
yeah lately we've made the conscious
decision to just like kind of stop for
the most part
my rule is like i'll read top three
commas yeah when you go deep you get you
get upset
don't go below the top three you'll feel
great and you'll have a great day
sometimes i see ila she's gone beyond
the top three i'm like you're in too
deep
bounce out now get out
i'm telling you and the same thing to me
too yeah don't go too deep
that's our rule
i have we have friends who do youtube
are like
i read every single comment
that to me
isn't is it i don't know how you could
live your life that way i almost don't
believe it it's like how
it's impossible yeah but not not only
not just like the is it physically or
time consuming like how do you handle
that many opinions about you it's
impossible to handle it's like you're
hearing
the thoughts of a million people
it's like uh
there's a superhero like yeah
he's out there you guys know what i'm
talking about
it's a superhero
it's called
jim carrey
it's called being a shitty it's called
being a youtuber i've got all these
voices in my head i don't have any
superpowers just a bunch of people
insulting me online
but i think i'm i think i don't mind it
as much now yeah
that's good
here's another question from the
subreddit that i'll phrase in their
voice logical defense says hey you know
my girlfriend relates a lot to you we
originally started watching you your
ethan and hila channel is a huge part of
our life
we're speaking as an outsider to your
relationship but it seems that sometimes
ethan's rather large personality can get
in the way of expressing your thoughts
on stream with that being said you and
ethan seem extremely happy with each
other and i'd like to know what you
think about this i'm asking because i
tend to be a very social person and find
myself in a sense steamrolling my
girlfriend in social environments what's
your opinion like how do you feel about
my personality overshadowing yours
sometimes or maybe me talking over you
stuff
i usually don't mind it because i
don't like being in the spotlight
anyway
so if you like
if you're kind of like taking the lead
and
taking more attention then i'm cool with
it because i don't want it
yeah so usually i feel like there's a
balance that i'm okay with i think i
sensed that yeah like sometimes i i
sense you're relieved for me to finish
your step your statement and so
interrupt but is there ever times where
i talk over and you're like
[ __ ] this guy dude
not really with you
not so much i think
it happens to me sometimes when we'll
hang out with people and then there's
like three
guys talking
i feel like i can't get a sentencing
because everyone's talking loud and very
assertive yeah
yeah but that's something else yeah
that's a different thing um shy people
problems
are you shy what are you what would you
consider are you shy person are you
introvert
i don't know
i'm just me baby i think i'm shy and
think i think i'm all of the obama but
you can also be very assertive i've seen
you assert yourself well beyond what i
would be comfortable with
on the other hand you know
it depends on the situation
that's that israeli side when i see you
look going like i'm going to this
person's door and i'm telling them they
got a problem and i'm like
i'm standing back on the sidewalk and
watch from here it's like this uh fuse
that like
if if someone like
if i get upset
then it's like it's a short
it and there's like a little fire
and it's very short right and then when
it like
it goes right and then i'm like
i get upset this [ __ ] needs to go down
yeah
um
if like i if i have a problem with uh
i don't know spectrum
then i'll i'll call them and i'll be
like get your [ __ ] together you know
sometimes i'm like ooh
but you got i mean you're look
it works man i think you're like your
assertiveness isn't it's not it depends
if i have a mission in my head or like
if it's a shoot or if we want to get a
video done
and we're missing a prop
so it's like no
i'm going to get that i'm going to get
that prop right i'm going to find it
yeah
um interestingly intuitively i think
you're a great producer and that you're
always focused on the task
and getting [ __ ] done you're good at
managing stuff and so like in terms of a
behind-the-scene partner like as we're
on partners and i'm like
the talent
that's what they call it i'm not trying
to conquer myself and you're behind the
scenes running like you're perfect at
that
i think that's the secret to our success
is that i am awful at managing my own
life or anything for that matter
and so that's a perfect balance i think
there
well and short to address this guy's
question
talk talk to her dude see if it annoys
her yeah i
for me i actually don't find it annoying
i sometimes i'm more comfortable that
way
i think we're just
we spent so much time talking and
interacting that like we read each other
yeah very well yeah i think ethan would
know if i wanted more
attention brought to me
i think you'll help me in a way when you
know that i don't want it
sometimes that comes off as like i see
this comment a lot and it does kind of
annoy me sometimes but it's like
whatever
they're like just let ela talk yeah stop
interrupting elon it's like
man everyone thinks i'm an interrupting
[ __ ]
yeah i think but i do feel like
sometimes i'm helping you yeah
to complete a statement
man i'm such a martyr dude i'm such a
great guy
i think the brunt of all i take it all
just for you yo
kidding
oh elaine's even so pop he's so arrogant
give me a [ __ ] break
um everyone knows by now that elon musk
is my dream podcast guest
so ela i'd like to ask you who is your
dream podcast guest
um i i saw that question you had some
time to think about that i knew yeah
that one was coming i didn't see all the
other questions i had no idea
but for that one i
i did think about it
i think
obviously larry david oh my god that'd
be crazy it'd be like i don't even know
if i want to meet him because i like him
too much i don't want to
[Music]
what if he got accused would that just
destroy you there is no way he didn't
have the balls there's it's larry david
there's no way
larry don't [ __ ] up ela's trust in you
man i'll bet you like my whole money
that he's never done anything like that
that's my money
no that bet's off the table um larry
david and i've
i thought about someone louie thoreau
love lewis
yeah
wow that could be possible louie's been
on joe rogan so he does
i mean clearly
i'm just saying it's possible yeah dan
write that down we're trying to make a
list of our dream guests louie thoreau's
got to be at the top yeah if you guys
don't know him oh check him out he makes
like the best documentaries the best
it's like not even documentaries like
yeah the
classical approach to making
documentaries is that you don't ever put
yourself in the documentary but his
approach is the exact opposite
he
just his personality is like an empty
slate
and he's got this super coy
and like manipulative i want to say
intelligently way of of making people
open up
and the most
thing and things that they should never
ever talk like they're in therapy with
this guy
on camera and he just goes just so
natural it just
happens yeah
yeah it's it's incredible i've we've
watched every single everything he's
made
can't recommend it i'm ready to re-watch
it all louie get your ass on the show
what would you ask him
see i don't know like i same with larry
david and him not sure
do you just want to hang out it's kind
of scary to meet someone that you really
like because i don't want to ruin it
like
for example i really like stranger
things
and i know that the finn one of the
actors he knows us and he follows us but
we never met him
and i kind of don't want to because i
love the show and i don't want
i don't want to ruin that image that i
have in my mind have we ever met
somebody that we really love like in
turn like on that level
uh
i'm not sure i mean
justin was kind of one just in royland
where we rick and morty yeah is a great
show that we loved and then we met him
but that one was was like
that one was so weirdly chill where it's
just like yeah come over and then we're
just like immediately just hit it off
great friends
but the one that i'm that i'm scared of
is like tim hi decker
he had that
he's like oh been my one of my uh
comedy idols i mean he's pretty much the
reason why we make youtube videos like
he had that big of an influence on me
especially in our early days and i have
a feeling
he's not the easiest guy to get along
with
yeah love him on the podcast by the way
dan add that
some consider you a fashion icon ela
this is weird that this was so high up
in the questions but people want to know
where do you get your slamming mom jeans
thank you
there's a lot of people
okay
uh
most of them i can say are from levi's
okay so there you go there you go but
why can't they find it
you gotta really
look through the websites and i buy it
on online
and
you just need to know your size and then
you can get whatever you need but they
have a lot of crap there like a lot of
really
shitty looking
you just gotta look through it and find
the good one i can say living with ila
she puts in a lot of work it's not easy
finding perfect mom jeans like you order
pants every day and send 90 of them back
not that often you're gonna make it
sound like a no but like you put in the
work you're studying you're looking
you're ordering you're sending back
you're taking notes
it's a lot of work guys you think
looking this good is easy no
no but that's like asking uh
shakespeare how do you write a
masterpiece
it takes a lot of work let's start there
you gotta you gotta look though i i'll
agree with that
but she she's
you're such a great uh pants looker
i wish
not that i could um
yeah have you always been interested in
fashion
i was actually
um when we first met i was gonna try to
go into fashion school
i mean i did try to go into fashion
school but i didn't get in
i got you got uh declined you got
declined by the decline so
i ended up waiting a year because
there's always like this season where
you can
sign up for school
and um the next year i signed up for art
and i got in so i ended up studying art
you being denied by fashion school is
kind of the best thing that ever
happened possibly because i don't know
that you would have ever come
and
stayed with me
yeah that happened
in between and also we made we started
making youtube videos because i studying
i was studying art
and i had this mandatory class of video
art right and i never made a video
before right every short video that was
the first time i had to do it so we did
something at home yeah and
that was how our youtube videos started
they were all my class assignments
i love that torturing your poor
classmates with our
yeah but there that goes to show you you
had to get
denied entry to fashion school to own
your own fashion company
and that will teach you a lesson kids
opportunities around every corner
you got to go through the doors
available to you if one gets closed
there's another one open keep slamming
raspberry farms are fertile
you just got to have this will to pick
him
did you ever expect like from then to
now that you would be owning your own
fashion company no no no
um i still don't
it's still like
we'll see where it goes i'm obviously
i'm very serious about it and i hope
that it will
grow into like a real fashion company
and a clothing line but
still fails really early to
be all proud about it but yeah of course
but i no i had no idea that it would
happen
it's just funny it's like a full circle
yeah what do you what is your long-term
vision for teddy fresh
um
i hope that it can be
like a serious brand you know that
people
know about and they know
the vibe of it and
it's got its own following
and
i hope to be able to make like
cool
uh kind of like high quality stuff but
for not that expensive like
i feel like you don't have that many
options like you have the h m and so on
urban outfitters and then you have the
super expensive stuff like gucci and
stuff no no one can afford right and
there's not a lot in between
strange but i found that it's very
strange that that's the case yeah and
like really highly designed really
beautiful high concept clothing that's
well made that doesn't cost a thousand
dollars per garment
and i just yeah i just hope that i can
create something that's a little
different
because i always feel like in my
drawings i have a certain
different vibe
that i i think it would be cool if i can
translate it into clothing
well
i'm pre
dude it's crazy i'm so proud of you like
thank you just to gush for a minute it's
insane like how much uh
how much work you've put into this and
how much focus
just on this first collection
on making a business
you have to have lawyers do copywriting
on your logo and trademarking you have
to find manufacturers designers like
the amount of work and focus that you
put into this
is is insane it's really difficult and
really time consuming
what's uh what like
what's going on behind the scenes that
you think people don't realize is so
hard about running a clothing company or
starting one
um
the mostly the
the fact that the whole process takes so
long
it takes so long
and the manufacturers
you know it takes
a few days to make is not a few it takes
maybe a few weeks to make a sample
and then if you want a certain custom
fabric they have to source the fabric
they have to
do lab dips to the certain color that
you want
and if you want a certain zipper and a
certain you know everything is like they
need to source it and it just really
takes a long time
and
and also it's not that cheap
at least it's starting because i don't
order that many pieces no it's not like
yeah crazy prices it's not in the
thousands so
yeah i don't get those crazy prices
so it's just uh
you gotta have patience i guess where
like i design it and i just wanna see it
already but i have to wait months in
between that's shocked me too yeah like
if you
like uh you're trying to make a
collection for winter
and it's gonna be like
like what's going on with that
collection like tell me about it i was
hoping to have it before christmas like
in december
and
it's already looking like there's no way
that's happening
so we're really trying to push to have
it in january and like we're really
pushing everyone
and so
i'm hoping we can get in january because
i'm i've designed winter clothes i don't
want it to come too late and then miss
the winter right so it's a lot of like
coordinating
of that stuff
and then once it's ready they need to
ship it and then there could be problems
with the shipment like on our last
batch of the first drop there was water
damage right of a bunch of boxes that
they had to redo yeah and then the
shipment there was there were delays
it's like
a lot of logistics and coordinating and
then in the same time you already have
to start working on spring yeah because
it takes so long
it takes like four months from concept
to selling at least yeah
it's crazy you said it's almost like
by the time you actually get to sell it
you almost don't even care about it
anymore
yeah because you're already in the
future working on new [ __ ] it's really
weird i feel different now when i see
the
yeah when i see the clothes because i'm
already like shifting my focus like two
collections next
i'll say though that winter collection
it's so sick dude i love everything on
it
i'm really excited i can't wait
cool
sick bro tell me uh what does teddy
fresh mean
how um
what what does uh
did you do make the designs yourself yes
okay
um
i i like to draw it by hand i don't know
illustrator very well more of a
photoshop person
and but i don't like drawing digitally i
just like
the paper and markers and pens i love
your sketches i wish i hope we can share
those someday oh yeah we should do it
so i like to actually draw the
clothes and
that's how i design it
very cool but certainly someday you're
going to have probably
you're going to need designers if you
want to build it into a big brand yeah
hopefully i can
understand myself what's the concept of
this brand so that i can explain it to
other people and we can
collaborate right
that's cool
i guess eventually you would just be
kind of the taste you'd be the judge at
the top who says
this represents my taste
but it's awesome that you're in the
trenches doing all that [ __ ] now so that
you understand how the company works
yeah eventually when you're not
doing all the designs by hand
um do you ask what's the dirty fresh
what does teddy fresh mean
um i just wanted something like
uh
like i like to do stuff that's like a
little childish
but
also not
like the contrast of like
um i don't know it's a little teddy bear
and
i just we actually thought about the
name together i made all kinds of
sketches for the teddy bear that's
actually the shirt the
the shirt that has all the teds
or was that all the those were all my
attempts at making the logo that's
awesome
and i just say i ended up drawing this
one and you liked it too
yeah it's great i love the logo so much
at first we weren't really sure on the
name but it really like it's settled i
like it i like it for sure
steady fresh dude forget about it
but i i always see you looking at like
kids clothing
as like your big inspiration
yeah i love it you guys should look at
kids clothing that [ __ ] is insane
they got such cool stuff and then if you
want to find it for adults you only find
it like gucci and it's 1600 yeah yeah
i don't know why how are these kids
getting a pass you have like this
insanely designed beautifully made
jacket that only like three-year-olds
can wear or like five-year-olds
and it's like 50 bucks how do they do
that i guess it's not a lot of material
but still the design is really high
level
i guess it's just not that common for
adults to be interested in it so it
becomes niche that's the thing the
designers they feel like they have this
license to be creative and wild
because it's a kid it's playful right
but it's actually amazing clothing and i
feel like that
design eye is just gone in adults but
it's like you said in gucci that's where
you see it
so it's like
let's let's bring it back i guess that's
your thesis of teddy fresh
kind of
yeah
cool
i like uh
i've always liked contrast like
take something childish and mix it with
something that's not or
things like that when i did art too
i was gonna say um you have a really
wonderful colorful unique art style
that a lot of people are really
appreciative of i feel like
um who are
your inspirations in art where do you
think you got that style from that taste
i
people always ask me that i don't really
have
like artists
that i
really follow or
that inspire me that much
there's some that i like but i i'm not
like an avid follower of anyone
um
[Music]
you told me the other day we were
walking through the museum in san diego
art and you said art is dead yeah what
did you
mean the whole experience of walking
into a museum
it's so sterile and you have to be quiet
and you have to be like
you have to look at a painting that
doesn't mean anything and you have to be
like oh i get it right when you don't
and it costs millions and you have no
idea why
and i just
don't get the whole i think it's so
old
was it at one point interesting what
happened to art
it was yeah
um
it always changes and there was the
realistic kind of drawing that was huge
you know and then
like back back back yeah yeah and then
there was a modern art that kind of took
it and like completely broke it
it's it i mean there were a lot of steps
in between sure but
i think like when jackson pollock
happened
that started that whole like abstract
which was more of a commentary on the
art that it proceeded yeah
and yeah at the time it was
valid commentary yeah
but i feel like uh
today
i it kind of created a lot of like lazy
art
that is just
it's just like
not much and it's a and
they also like they're all so full of
themselves in art
there was this scene there was this
famous um
there was this huge thing ready made art
and
like all these different art paradigms
like you were saying ultra realism yeah
impressionism whatever they all are an
interesting commentary cubism and so in
that in that it's easy to look back and
be like oh that's not that interesting
but in the time it was important
and that's and so there was ready-made
art that was important when it happened
like this one guy yeah
urinal mm-hmm and that was like what
year was that from
i actually don't know the year
50s you can look it up marcel duchamp
but when he made it he was like he took
a urinal that he just bought from like a
home depot right kind of store and
he put it in the museum and said this is
art 1917
ian said that was a hundred years ago
that's crazy and back then that was a
that was like brilliant right
it was like a parody was a satire of
self-aware yeah and since then i feel
like people are like oh ready-made art
they like miss the whole point and
they're just putting random [ __ ]
this is really popular still but random
[ __ ] call it art and it's like dude you
missed the point the urinal was the joke
and that was a hundred years ago yeah
and it's like
you walk through museums and it's just
it's time capsules that doesn't mean
anything to anyone anymore yeah and
there's nothing interesting happening
and when i when i went to art school
they kind of teach you this like
they kind of it's i kind of see it as a
quote they have like this way of living
that you're supposed to follow where you
need to be obsessed with art galleries
and every week there's art openings and
you're supposed to be going to all of
them right and be following all that
stuff and like you got to be miserable
i remember one of your teachers saying
something up to you about our
relationship yeah you say she said she
doesn't think you can make art while
being in a happy relationship like [ __ ]
yes it's a contradiction
maybe in your life you said miserable
um
i just find it all funny i don't that
really pissed me off by the way yeah you
told me she said that i was like who the
[ __ ]
you sorry your life sucks so does your
art probably and the funny fact about
her we had two courses in a year yeah
the second one she just didn't show up
yeah she's miserable she's off being
miserable somewhere
um
i just said
don't don't relate to the art scene
anymore i don't know if i ever did i
like art in a way but
i don't really like the art scene
and
so when when we go to the museum i
really don't like the experience it's so
boring it's just old like we're living
in this ditch this wonderful digital age
i feel like any interesting art now
needs to be interactive in some way it
needs to be playful it needs to be
colorful needs to be stimulating and fun
there's nothing that will excite any
human on this earth about a painting on
a wall
that's like it's just it's just doesn't
do anything anymore yeah at one point it
did
but i think your description of it being
like a cult is really accurate because
it's like everyone walks around like oh
yeah art let's go to the museum and
meanwhile you know everyone is like this
i would this is awful i hate it mm-hmm
what was that great kavanagh quote about
art remember that
something about like art is just a
conspiracy between the rich yeah to make
the poor people feel down yeah
god bless kirpanagit um i also i when
people always ask me about inspiration
i just don't really
[Music]
i don't really see it that way like if i
look at a bunch of stuff it's
interesting and it's good to know
what's going on good to know the history
and all that but when i draw i try to
like i actually don't look at anything i
don't like you specifically don't want
outside no
i feel like it's distracting and
it's exhausting me if i go to if i see
something that i like
it's actually exhausting it's like i
don't i can never make that it's kind of
like depressing me interesting
so i don't even like it i don't i just
if i draw i'm just gonna
put on music and just not look at
anything
do you have favorite artists today who
are making modern or i would even call
it post-modern i don't know
there's some famous artists that i
do like like uh
takashi murakami i want to pull up some
of their art because i if you like them
then they must be amazing how do you
spell that
more here i got it
let's see
so these look at this this [ __ ] is
insane
when it doesn't exhibit i've never been
to his exhibitions but when he does one
it's like the whole space is designed
you're basically entering a world yeah
here he is
and this [ __ ] is crazy
dude
look at the [ __ ] that is so nuts
it's like anime
it's really awesome i just like reduced
this yeah no he does
it does do stuff with anime if you type
sculpture here's a very famous really
sculpture of like an anime creature
girl
when you'll see
oh this one here
stuff like that oh my god i can't show
that
what the [ __ ] was that it's art you can
show it oh yeah it's hard we can show
that yeah get off my back twitch
dance blur that put a blur over that
please and another one is yeah can i
just describe it it's goku with a lasso
jerking off a massive erection
so
but damn
for real blur that i know it's art so
get off my back youtube and twitch but
dan just to be safe because i respect
them and our audience
another one is
what's their name y-a-y why a-y
the first one
okay
oh [ __ ] yeah this lady's nuts look at
this installation like this is art like
you walk into a museum that looks like
this you're like oh right man i'm i'm
i'm experiencing something
that outfit by the way
so i like them okay i see why no i
definitely see why
look at this lady
shit's crazy what even is this look at
this
this is like an installation with
mirrors and yeah like infinity or
pumpkins or something yeah
wow
cool
i can definitely see what what you see
in this
wow this isn't they're both very famous
by now very established artists look at
this
another infinity infinity mirror
so is this an installation yeah
cool
nice
good taste
um
what's your favorite video we've made
on h3
and on ethan and ela or do you have one
in particular that you really love
um
uh i guess like the obvious one is vape
nation yeah
um the modern art i like yeah that was a
lot of fun making
um
for obvious reasons yeah as we've just
spoken about
the 90s boy band yes
i almost got killed making that one yeah
ela likes the ones where i'm most
humiliated essentially
i'm right there with you yeah you're
there
oh niton and
i like the waterpark video the summer
look definitely my favorite i love that
video i also enjoyed making the black
challenge or whatever we called it where
we just
bought black products like it didn't
even make any sense and we just uh yeah
that was a lot of fun it kind of sucks i
missed those videos i feel like on h3 if
we put those videos up now people
wouldn't be receptive
and we just don't really have the energy
to make those videos just to put on
ethernet
you know
yeah
it's weird we combined the channels and
now i kind of feel like if we
like we would have to split it again if
we made those videos it sucks it's
annoying
like we were gonna shoot a dumb products
video we're basically like those ones we
used to make yeah and we're just like i
don't know if we can post this on h3
like everyone's gonna get angry they're
not gonna like it
it's frustrating
um how was the experience of making
ethan and ela videos and being on and
then all of a sudden being in front of
the camera every day for a long time
uh it's
it's good it's uh
it's not easy
for me but it's kind of like therapy in
a way it's something that i
i like to improve so
it's kind of good
what is it like uh
it's i because i feel like sometimes you
just need to push yourself through
whatever is difficult yeah even when i
draw when i sit to draw
it would take me maybe like an hour to
just start to actually draw
once i get into it i will enjoy it but
i don't know why there's like
all these
feelings of like uh i don't want to do
this let me just check my email and put
this aside and right let me do something
else before i start
do you feel like you're less shy or do
you just power through it
because you're like i have to do this
i guess it's kind of both
i maybe i am less shy but i also
power through it if i feel nervous right
yeah
so i guess finally i'll wrap it up here
with one last question
you're inside the h3h3
behind the scenes of what's going on
there what are some challenges
that people don't see is there something
that you wish people knew or understood
about h3 or what goes on there with
making videos
what is it people don't see that you
wish they understood is i don't know
it's kind of a broad question
um what's something maybe that just
people don't know about h3 that
is [ __ ]
dub
not sure
um
i guess uh
i it's it's sometimes they
like for example now that we haven't
posted a lot
um
i feel like maybe people don't know how
much we are actually
thinking about it all the time and are
concerned about it
maybe they think we're just like oh
let's just go hang out at the pool and
not post anything for two weeks
but we're actually like stressed about
the fact that we're not posting for two
weeks i mean while working on others
it's not
it's not because of our decision not to
post it sometimes it's just
it becomes sometimes difficult to make
videos and
you do it for so long and you you start
changing and then maybe you need to
change the content or not
it just becomes kind of
there's like periods
where it kind of like becomes
we've been through like three periods
where it was super super hard to make
content and i feel like we're in one now
mm-hmm and besides that we're super busy
with all this other stuff with like
the podcast your fashion company
something else that's going on that we
can't talk about but it's really big
yeah and so
i don't know yeah it's hard to know if
it's that all that stuff
or if we're just in a phase
it's so it's tough man it's hard and i
feel and i also simultaneously feel like
we're betraying
in a way our fans who really do want
like when we walk outside and people are
super nice and say how they love our
videos and stuff
and it's like man i want to make videos
for those guys
but it's so sometimes it's so hard i
don't know why
yeah
huh
[ __ ] me dude
in other words we're out here we're
trying
just be patient with us all right well
ela i love you i appreciate you thank
you for muscling through that i know
it's not easy for you thank you it must
have been
very challenging and by the way it's
almost been two hours really two hours
your ass has been talking about [ __ ]
that's crazy that's pretty i i'm
so i give it up i tip my beanie to you
i appreciate you thank you for everyone
watching and being interested in what i
have to say
[Laughter]
oh man
you're the best
um
we don't have a guest next week but
we're working on i think possibly post
malone will be here next week
not 100 certain so i don't want to pen
that in but we're working on that and a
couple other cool guests coming up
um thanks for joining us guys thanks as
always for spending your day with us and
and uh coming along on this wild booth
um
yeah thank you i really appreciate you
coming and muscling through that's yeah
god bless you
and um
listen
you guys are just great
love you a lot
we'll see you next time bye guys thank
you bye